hey everyone how's it going so today I'm
gonna show you how to use Xcode apple's
ide to create iOS apps also thanks again
to Squarespace for sponsoring today's
video whether you need a domain or a
website or an online store make it with
Squarespace cool so today is the second
part of a two-part series on iOS
development I'm making these because WWC
is next month and I thought what better
chance to talk about iOS development
than this and I want y'all to get hyped
about iOS development with me by the way
I made a video about how to get started
into iOS development where I talk about
what I think are the most helpful
resources to get started so don't forget
to check that out ok so I wanted to make
this video because as I mentioned in my
last video when I was starting Iowa swap
mint which was a class that I took in
college called mobile programming the
very first office hours that we had with
the TA was going over how to use Xcode
up until that point I had stuck like a
tonne iOS Weltman before and I had
downloaded and opened Xcode but I just
didn't know how to use it I had no idea
what all the buttons meant so I wanted
to make a video where I show you how to
use Xcode I have an iOS developer for
about 4 years so I think I know my way
around
Xcode pretty well now so I wanted to do
this for y'all in case y'all are also
stuck on how to use Xcode I hope that
this is at least going to help set some
foundation so that y'all can get started
also this will probably be one of the
very few if not one of the only
technical tutorials on my channel
because I don't want to make a tutorial
channel but there are a lot of other
great channels that do this and so I'll
leave this in the comments down below
but I'm hoping that this still be fun
and engaging and interesting for y'all
even if you don't care about Xcode
because I don't know I'd like to believe
that you like watching my videos cool so
we're gonna do like a whole screen share
you think I got my mic set up and I
guess we'll just get started ok so I
just want to go over some prerequisites
with y'all unfortunately you can only
make iOS apps Mac OS apps TV OS watch OS
apps on a Mac so you do have to have a
Mac machine in order to run Xcode you
could do like a cool virtual environment
thing where you have like a Mac instance
that also has Xcode but yeah you have to
have some sort of Maxis
that you can run xcode on in order for
it to run cool so let's get started i
just updated my xcode and so i'm running
version 9 31 which is the newest one as
of today's recording this is the first
screen you'll see when you download
Xcode you can download Xcode from the
Mac App Store and it's super easy to do
granted it's a pretty big file size so
just make sure in a good connection so
here it is let's just kind of walk
through like I want to get the setup
that you have when you're working on an
Xcode project so I'm gonna click on
create an Xcode project that is going to
bring up another screen here we go
alright so most of the time I just use
single view app all these other ones are
for like extensions if you want to make
a game if you make a sticker pack app
this setup is slightly different but
most of the time if you're just gonna
make your own app you're just gonna
select single view app so I'm gonna
click that and then let's call this I
don't know hello yeah that's good
it's the only thing you really have to
worry about maybe is like products name
organization name doesn't really matter
if you're just like coding on the side
and for fun this will matter if you are
gonna submit the app to the App Store
though but it's something you can
actually change later on so not that big
of a deal
same with the bundle identifier the
language that you're gonna choose is the
language you're gonna program in so I
think for most of y'all you'll probably
be be coding in Swift so there's that
you can leave these checked unchecked
doesn't really matter like having it
checked versus unchecked means that it
just sets up certain things or a project
for you but you can also uncheck these
and then add them later that's not a
part of the setup process so you can
just do that you can click Next I think
it's gonna ask for what you save so it's
just
you're perfect so this is going to be
the standard Xcode screen so let me make
this pretty big okay so on this screen I
just want to show you around a little
bit so this main block right here this
kind of like big the biggest section of
Xcode is going to be kind of like your
main file place your main file viewer
right now this is open to the actual
project settings but if you click into
like new controller Swift you'll see
that this is where the code goes so this
is like your code editor project
settings editor etc so most of the work
that you'll be doing isn't here so let's
walk through from kind of like top left
and then kind of work sort of clockwise
so in the top left you see a play button
here this is actually going to run your
app so if I just click this it'll you'll
see that like my app hello is going to
run an iPhone 8 plus you can actually
select different simulator devices here
so you can see how it works on different
devices which is really nice and it just
all comes with Xcode so you don't have
to download anything extra at all so
it's going to launch the app here and
let's see where my simulator comes out
to and so this app it's like doesn't
really do anything right now so you'll
see that when the simulator launches it
doesn't really do anything but out of
the box you know an extra project is
always just gonna run and work perfect
great so here's our app it's completely
playing completely white but this is
what you get when you just don't do
anything so yeah that's how you run your
app and then when you want to stop it
you can just say you say stop which is a
stop button and then
it'll just stop it and then all bring
you back to home screen which I think
y'all are pretty familiar with cool so
there's that
okay now let's dive into the kind of
like this left panel real quick there's
a lot of things going up on here but
most of the time you're gonna be on the
file browser so this is going to show
all of the files that you use for the
app and so if you click it once thing
you'll just open that file I mean that
storyboard is going to contain
storyboards for your app it's more like
a WYSIWYG type of tool so you don't
really have to worry about this stuff
right now like this this is just you
click once and then it just opens the
file for you so that's pretty
straightforward these other things are
nice things that come with Xcode so you
can actually do source control through
Xcode so you can see all the branches
that you have as well as the current
status for them I don't have a github
repo set up here but that's one thing
you can do this what is this oh this is
I guess like a class and function
navigator so like I have an app delegate
class and these are all the different
functions so if you click application
will terminate it opens to that place so
I actually didn't know these existed
pretty cool I actually don't really use
it very much but I think it just indexes
your app for you and you can just go
into these things pretty quickly here's
a search function which I use pretty
often to find stuff so let's say I want
to find a very specific function called
viewdidload so that's how you can search
things there it's pretty straightforward
you can like you know search for very
specific things you can match case
ignore case pretty cool this is where
you're going to see like build time and
run time errors so if you have like a
compile error so let's just like add
some of the garbage here and then you
try to build it it's going to give you a
compile error and it will slash should
show up right here cool so now this is
like what what is this I don't know what
you're doing so delete it so yeah ice
code is nice because it kind of comes
with all those things built in has a
compiler
has a thing so like even if you're like
typing here it should like give me an
error maybe not anyways yeah excuse
really nice because it has a bunch of
these things built in so you know build
time errors runtime errors sometimes
they'll show up in line sometimes they
won't depending on like how fast your
computer is and what version of X here
you're running on but it's pretty nice
it's all it's all there this one is for
test if you have tests for them you can
run them through here don't worry about
that too much if you are debugging
something and you have a breakpoint and
this is where your stack is going to
show so let's do here let's put a
breakpoint here and you do that by just
like clicking the line you can disable
it by clicking again and you can remove
it by dragging it away so yeah so like
if I run this then you'll see that it
will break here and your lines will show
up right here or your call stack and now
it's launching and it should why uh here
we go it just took a little while great
so now you have a breakpoint and it's
it's broke there basically so this is
gonna show you all the threads that are
running as well as like what function is
called what so you can see that if you
called several functions and they're
nested they'll all show up here down
here actually while we're in this kind
of like debug session here are all the
controls that you would use to debug
stuff so here's kind of like the play
pause button step over step in to step
out those are kind of like the basic
debugging like controls you would have
in other apps as well and they're pretty
straightforward there so yeah this is
also going to show you kind of like what
variables you have and the values of
those variables sometimes they'll show
up and sometimes they won't depending on
how Xcode parses them but say like maybe
I want to see what the launch options
there are
Xcode comes with this thing called lldp
which is like your debugging tool kind
of it's like gdb for those of you know
that and so I use it sometimes
and print out statements basically to
see what the values are so let's say I
want to see what's inside launch options
I'm gonna type P O stands for print out
launch options and then it should print
out what lunch
launch options there are I'm in a little
bit of an older Mac and so it might take
a little bit but it'll come ah it's no
so that's pretty handy if you need to
see like the values of different things
and just check your logic and so yeah so
I'm just gonna let this go by continuing
and then I'm gonna remove this lot for
now cool so yeah that's kind of where
your debug session stuff will show up
also if you have breakpoints and several
of them they also show up here so it's
gonna add a couple and they'll show up
on the left side you can also remove
them from here which is pretty nice or
you like disable them so yeah dude good
debugging tooling this one is going to
show you all of the like sessions that
you ran and so I built one I such a big
thing here is like where that compiler
error happened where I like and that
garble and yeah if you want to see what
you know messages there were my errors
there where you want to really dive into
that that's cool but I wanna say you
don't really have to worry about that
all that much and so let's go back to
view controller dot Swift
okay so I've covered kind of like the
left hand side a little bit now let's
focus our attention to the right hand
side starting from the very top right
okay so on the right hand side top right
alright so you're gonna see these three
buttons so let's hover over the first
one this says show the standard editor
so Standard editor basically just means
that you have one file open and you have
the latest changes reflected in that
editor if you click this one actually
though this the assistant editor it kind
of gives you this dual pane type of deal
and so you can have one file over here
and another file over here so you can
have two classes open at once so let's
say on how view controller dot Swift and
appdelegate dot Swift then
you can open it side-by-side you can
also browse through it from here
so that's pretty handy as well so you
can just kind of like look at two things
at once which I do most of the time as
long as I have a big enough screen to do
so because most of the time I'm like
figuring out how two classes will
interact and stuff so yeah assistant
editor is there I believe there is more
you can do you can do like top and
bottom assistant editor stuff if you
click into the triangle there's like
just like a bunch of stuff that you can
do but most of the time I just have
assistant editors on write so yeah
that's that's kind of the basic thing
there and then this one see what comes
up show the version editor so the
version editor will show you the
different versions that you've committed
to version control so this project
doesn't have anything but you would see
like oh this side has like the latest
change and then you can compare it to a
change from two or three commits ago
that's pretty handy so then you can see
like the incremental changes that
someone has made to a file and so yeah
it's pretty easy to just like look at
those things and tell what happened to a
file and they use that pretty frequently
as well cool okay so now let's go to the
these three kind of horizontal box type
things so these are kind of hide or show
buttons and they all correspond to
different parts of Xcode so this
left-hand side you'll see it's marked
blue because this is to hide or show the
navigator which is this left-hand side
bar here so if I want to hide it I just
click it and then it's gone and then if
I want to show it again comes up
similarly to the debug menu show/hide
and then the right-hand side like this
as well so theoretically you could just
have the editor and that's it and so
that's pretty cool too okay cool so now
let's go to this right-hand bar so this
is kind of the editor that's going to
help you write code it's going to show
you kind of the properties of this file
like where it lives what it's called
what's the target membership which means
like what does it get compiled for as
well as just like
some other things and so for a regular
like dot Swift file it's pretty standard
like there's not a whole lot here but if
you open main dot storyboard which I
told you is like the WYSIWYG editor then
there's a lot more you can do so you
note you'll notice that there's like a
lot more things here but how about we
just try to add like a button to this
screen and see what happens
so there's this neat thing down here
where you can just kind of like drag and
drop different UI components so there's
labels buttons segmented controls pretty
straightforward and so I want a button
so I'm going to drag it to the screen
and then Center it and voila now I have
a button great okay
now that I have a button I think these
controls are going to make a little bit
more sense to you so the I didn't what
is this thing called the file thing file
inspector file inspector hasn't really
changed pretty straightforward quick
help is going to show you kind of the
documentation I guess of what that
button is and so this is coming directly
from the Apple documentation and then
this is the what is this the identity
inspector so this is going to yeah you
can add some more stuff here too like
the this wall you can associate this to
like an actual UI button class but I
think the real magic is like this
attributes inspector where you can
actually customize what this says so
let's call this like you know let's
change the title to say hello and then
let's say and then what's I don't know
change the text color to like this free
salmon color yeah let's do that and then
maybe we can bump up the font size a
little bit let's say something nice and
big like this cool see and then you can
see like there's a bunch of other like
things you can customize for the view
and then
over here you'll see this is kind of
like the what is this the size inspector
so you can kind of change how this
button is sized and placed here's a
connections inspector so if you connect
to this button to be like an action then
it'll all show up here this will
probably all make sense if you go
through a tutorial that kind of shows
you how to do all of this but for now I
just want to get you familiar with all
these different screens ray Wonderlic
tutorials are really great because they
usually do stuff on a storyboard and
they'll show you exactly where to click
to do all the different things that you
want to do so I really recommend going
through one of his tutorials because
then you can see how all this comes into
play but this is just me like showing
you where all the things are so I hope
that this is helpful but yeah other than
that that's kind of it this is this is
Xcode there's a lot more things hidden
within these menus obviously there's
also a lot of hotkeys that you can learn
but I'm not gonna go over that today but
just to get yourself oriented I hope
this is helpful so yeah if you have any
other really specific questions about
Xcode or like you know there's a button
you don't know how to use or there's
something you don't know how to do leave
a comment down below also alternatively
look it up on the internet like a bunch
of other people always post different
things about how to use Xcode and when
they get stuck so a lot of stuff online
for you but other than that I hope this
is helpful
cool so that's it for today thank you
all so much for watching I hope you
liked today's video today's video is a
little bit out of the ordinary and a
little bit out of my comfort zone for me
honestly but I hope you found it useful
and fun nonetheless as always if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to my channel I will be
vlogging as much as I can of Deborah
Dodie see it is the first week of June
and so I will be posting a vlog of that
when I go so thanks again to Squarespace
for sponsoring today's video I think
that whether you need a personal website
to have your own portfolio on or you
want to make a tech blog for yourself
Squarespace is a great solution to that
they have beautiful designer templates
that look really professional and
beautiful and so they're ready to go for
you to use
it's an all on platform so you never
have to install a patch or upgrade ever
which means that you can spend more time
thinking about where you're gonna put on
your website and then figuring out how
it's gonna work
they have award-winning 24/7 customer
service so whether you're up at 2 a.m.
or 6 a.m. or 2 p.m.
customer service reps are ready to help
you out it's also really easy to set up
or transfer a domain on Squarespace and
so you can set one up that is very fit
to your own personality so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace comm slash my eco for 10%
off your purchase of a website or domain
and it's it for today I'll see you next
time bye why are humans made to choke on
your own spit it's like ro it's like we
were made to die and my ass I'm wearing
heard me chewing boba